[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
القضيه هي ان تضع العميل الصحيح في المكان
الصحيح
ابتداء من تجنيد العميل مرورا بتوفير
وتشغيل الاجهزه التقنيه كل شيء يتحرك في
وقت
[موسيقى]
واحد بدون عميل لا يمكن الوصول بدون عميل
لا يمكن عمل اي
شيء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عمليات معقده ومهمات كبرى تحتاج خطه امنيه
عاليه ومعلومات استخباراتيه وتفاصيل دقيقه
لاختراق الجدران الامنيه المحيطه بالهدف
كانت نتيجتها افشال لعمليات عسكريه
واغتيالات لقاده المقاومه الفلسطينيه لم
تكن اسرائيل لتنجح فيها لولا وجود عنصر
بشري على
الارض هذا العنصر كان وما زال يشكل صندوقا
اسود بكل
تفاصيله قررنا ان نقترب من هذا العالم
الغامض ونبحث في كيفيه تجنيد هؤلاء
العملاء ما هي ادوارهم
كيف يعملون وما هي الخطوره التي يشكلونها
على المجتمع الفلسطيني باشرنا البحث عن
بدايه
[موسيقى]
الخيط التحدي الاول الذي واجهنا هو ان
نتمكن من التحدث الى عميل بشكل
مباشر اثناء البحث وجدنا معلومات عن عميل
قام باقتحام السفاره التركيه في اسرائيل
مطالبا بحق اللجوء السياسي في تركيا
تمكن حراس السفاره من اخراجه بعد ان
اطلقوا النار عليه واصابه برجله وتم نقله
فيما بعد الى السجن تبين لاحقا ووفقا
لمحاميه ان العميل ويدعى نديم انجاص مطلوب
من السلطه الفلسطينيه لتخاف مع جهاز الامن
الداخلي الاسرائيلي وانه منذ ان تم كشفه
فر هاربا الى اسرائيل توجهنا لمحامي نديم
في محاوله للاتصال به داخل السج
بزم بدايات عام
2000 ساعد نديم دوله اسرائيل في الجانب
الامني يوجد في السجن هاتف
عمومي وطاعه نديم الاتصال من
خلال وجد فيه في
الساحه لا يمكنني ان اتصل به فهذه الهواتف
مخصصه للمكالمات من السجن الى الخارج
وتعمل بواسطه
[موسيقى]
بطاقه ال
مرحبا اهلا نم كيف
حال
الامور جيده نحن الان قريبون جدا جدا
منك الخارج قرب سجن
شرون طبعا نعم صحيح امسكنا بطرف الخيط
وتمكنا من التواصل هاتفيا مع نديم بشكل
مباشر متعاون مع الشباك من
سنه6
2002 انا كنت اشتل مع خليه من فتره حقولي
الشباك عرضوا علي منعي شك التلابيب بتاجل
لك بيت ومسكوره ومش عارف شو كان ياخذ مني
معلومات عن التنظيمات في رام الله وين في
سلاح وين شغلات زي هي اشفت في عمليه ان
سلمت ناس في تلفيف ويوم ما نزلوا الخليه
هي ب تعمل العمليه هي ان مسكوا فاهم و بس
الطريقه اللي نزلوها ما زبطت انكشفت انا
بالحاله ها وبكرم الله عرفوا علي انه انا
انه انا بشتم على الشبا
انا صار برم الله يهددوا متوني والشباك
حناياك وصلت لقرار انه خلص ما
فيش قيمه لحياتي يعني فقررت انه اروح اشوف
لجوء سياسي ف دول السفاره علمنا منه بوجود
عدد من العملاء يقبعون داخل السجن
لارتكابهم مخالفات جنائيه واخرى تتعلق
بعدم وجود تصاريح تسمح لهم بالاقامه داخل
اسرائيل عندي حوالي 20 كله بخليهم يحق ومن
الناس اللي تعال كمان وصفوا عالم كمان
بانتظار مكالمه ثانيه من نديم تابعنا
التحقيق وكان الهدف التالي ان نتمكن من
مقابله عميل خارج السجون بعد بحث مطول
تمكنا من الوصول لرقم هاتف عميل يدعى صادي
يقيم في بتاح تكفا في اسرائيل بقيت محاوله
مقابلته مستمره اخلف موعده الاول والثاني
بعد الحاح كان
اللقاء صعدي متهم بالعماله في الضفه
الغربيه وقد هرب لاسرائيل بعد ان تعرض
هناك لاطلاق الرصاص عليه وتهديده رافقنا
الى مكان سكنه حيث يعيش في ملجا تحت الارض
وباوع اقل ما يقال عنها انها
مزريه
[موسيقى]
جيت على اسرائيل المخابرات الاسرائيل
تعالوا يا عمي انا انتخ علي ولا
معي
ولاشك مض
قلاك ماهم السلطه بدهم ضيعوني وانا الانهم
ان جاس معكم مي قك ماب ف تقبلو في وين
اروح يعني زي ما انت شايف قبلان هذا
العيشي ولا قبل قبلان العار
لنفس يقول فلان جاسوس او فلان هرب على
اسرائيل صار جاسوس مع اسرائيل انكر صادي
ان يكون قد تعاون مع الاحتلال باي شكل او
قدم لهم اي معلومه الا ان لجوءه للمخابرات
الاسرائيليه ابقى الشك قائما تابعنا
الحديث معه من اجل الحصول على معلومات
تفيد بمقابله عملاء اخرين فذكر في حديثه
عميلا يدعى عبد الحميد رجوب عبد الحميد
رجوب بقول اكبر عميل كان اكبر تاجر اسلحه
في الضفه وكان مسؤول مجموعه تنظيم تفجرات
في داخل
اسرائيل عبد الحميد الرجو اسم ثير للجدل
ومن متصدري قائمه العماله والتخابر مع
الاحتلال صدر بحقه قرار بالاعدام في الضفه
الغربيه اثر ادانته بالتخابر
بدانا محاولات حثيثه لاقناعه بالحديث معنا
ليكون اول ظهور له على وسائل اعلام
عربيه السبعينات قد عمليه ضخمه في القدس
على الجيش الاسرائيلي مين ينفذها سوينا
قرعه وفي النهايه اخوي نفذها
وانحبس بنفس الليله مع ما انا اتهمت يعني
الاعداء خلينا نسميها قالوا لاخوي اخوك وز
عليك فلما التقينا بعد ما طلع في تبادل
الاسر بعد 15 عام قلت انت اتهمتني قال لي
صحيح قلت له انت جبان قال انا قلت له
جبان قاللي ليش جبان قلت له عرفت الحقيقه
قال قلت له وقف مثل الزلام وقول اخوي بري
انا ما خنت فت هم بقولوا عندي خاين وعميل
يقولوا شو بدهم قضيه بتيني بس انا بعتبر
نفسي انا شنيت حرب
عفتح عبد الحميد قام باعمال اضرت في
المصالح الوطنيه العليا الفلسطينيه اضرت
في ناس ابرياء ليس لهم ذنب في موضوع
الانتقام الاعمى الذي قام به وهو قام ب
يعني يبرر
اي ان يخون شعبه و ويقدم معلومات لعدو
شعبه زي يعني زي اللي بيهرب من المطر تحت
المزراب يعني هو هارب من ظلم وقع عليه
ليدعم اكبر ظالم له ولشعبه كيف يمكن لمحتل
ينكل بشعب يعايش الظلم بصوره يوميه ان
يقنع ضعاف النفوس للتعاون معه كيف يختارهم
وكيف يجري اسقاطهم في وحل
العماله مجددا تلقينا مكالمه هاتفيه من
نديم وهذه المره اتاح لنا فرصه الحديث الى
عميل يقبع حاليا في السجن لعدم امتلاكه
تصريح اقامه في اسرائيل سالناه كيف سقط في
العماله الموضوع بلش من
الطيبه تعرفنا على مخابرات مشان ضبطنا
التصريح مشان نقدر نشت باسرائيل
ليس العامل وحده هو من يحتاج ان يستصدر
تصريحه بنفسه بل على كل فلسطيني يعبر
الحاجز وحتى المرضى منهم ان يستصدر
التصريح
بانفسهم هذا ما اكدته لنا هداس ذا ايف من
منظمه اطباء لحقوق
الانسان كان من مهام قسم الاراضي المحتله
في منظمه اطباء لحقوق الانسان مساعده
المرضى الفلسطينيين في الحصول على تصاريح
للمجيء الى المستشفيات لكنهم واجهوا شرطا
بان يتم التحقيق في الامر اولا من قبل
الشباك فنشات مشكله نحن هل يفترض ان ننسق
الامور مع الشباك فتركنا القرار للمرضى ان
ارادوا الذهاب لمقابله الشباك لان هذا شرط
دخولهم لم نجد اي جهه مدنيه لاستصدار
تصريح دخول لاسرائيل مهما تعددت الاسباب
ولا بد ان يمر التصريح على الشباك اولا
ماذا يريد الامن الاسرائيلي من الحواجز
باعتبارها نقاط احتكاك مباشر مع
الفلسطينيين توجهنا بسؤالنا هذا لمسؤول سق
في الشباك يدعى روني
شكيد من اجل تجنيد شخص ما يجب التفكير في
شخص يكون من قلب ذلك المكان ويكون لديه
الدافعيه ونقاط ضعف من خلالها استطيع
تجنيده اين يمكن لي ان التقي به للمره
الاولى وكيف انشئ اتصال الاوليه به هناك
من يذهب للمدرسه وهناك من ياتي الى الحاجز
وهناك من يذهب لمستشفى
هداس بعد فتره بدات تصلنا تقارير تفيد بان
الشباك لا يجري فحصا امنيا وانما يطلب
منهم التعاون كشرط للحصول على التصريح
كانت هناك حاله قيل له مباشره وضعك الصحي
غير جيد فان لم تساعدنا فلتذهب ولتم في
غزه اثناء التحقيق وصلنا لسيده في غزه
تدعى هدايه تعرضت للضغط عندما توجهت
لمستشفى تلها شمير في اسرائيل لعلاج ابنها
زين سمحوا لها بالدخول في المره الاولى
وعندما قرر الاطباء عمليه ضروريه لابنها
تواصل معها الشباك للحصول على معلومات
كشرط لدخولها هذه المره قالت لي احنا يعني
حابين انه نساعدك وحنو لك افضل دكتور وحنج
لك بروفيسور من امريكا حتى يعمل لك عمليه
ابنك بس انه انت تساعدينا في شغلنا قلت
لها بس طبعا انا ما في مجال اني اساعد
قالت لي طب ما خلص يعني اذا كان انت ما
بدكي تتعاون ليش تيجي تتعالجي عننا قلت
لها لانه احنا يعني ما في مكان ثاني
الواحد بده يروح عليه قالت لي خلص يبقى يا
اما التعاون يا اما
العلاج اكدت لنا الاجهزه الامنيه في غزه
روايه هدايه بعد ان لجات لهم رافضه
التخابر مع الاحتلال اردنا ان نسمع
لتفاصيل اكثر عن طرق اسقاط العملاء
فتوجهنا الى الرجل المسؤول عن التحليل
النفسي للعملاء الذين يجري التحقيق معهم
بعد اعتقالهم ويدعى اسلام شهوان كانت في
لدينا قصه حقيقيه لشاب تم اسقاطه عن طريق
فتاه وهذه الفتاه مارست دور المعجبه
ومارست دور العشق والحب مع هذا الشاب وقام
هذا الشاب سلك الطريق الحدوديه الشرقيه
لقطاع غزه ثم تفاجا هذا الشاب ان من كان
بانتظاره هو ضابط المخابرات وبدات المسا
من خلال المكالمات التي تم تسجيلها الطرق
التي كشفت حتى الان هي بثلاث اشكال كل
الاشكال الثلاث هي اسمها استغلال الحاجه
الانسانيه فاحيانا
بالمال احيانا بالجينس واحيانا في حاجه
الناس مثلا الى قضيه ما الى تصريح حاجه
الناس هي التي يستغلها
الاحتلال
كان لابد من مقابله افراد عملوا على تجنيد
العملاء عن قرب للتعرف على اساليب اسقاطهم
يوبق تحكي لان يعقوب شت وزير كوزير يحكي
لو عضو كني بدر بس الوظيف انا بخليك
تقابلي ناسم اسرا
حسوني صديقي
وزميلي ض يعقوب حاليا ورئيس الشباك حتى
العام 95 المقابله بينما وافق نائب رئيس
الشباك سابقا وهو عضو في الكنيست
الاسرائيلي حاليا اسرائيل حسون ان يتحدث
الينا باشرنا بسؤاله عن الضغوطات التي
تمارسها اسرائيل من اجل تجنيد
العملاء في هذا العمل لا يمكن للشخص ان
يعمل ان لم يكن
مخلصا لم تكن مخلصا فاترك ولا تضيع وقتك
لذا
ضغطوا ويضغطون ويضغطون وا جبروني ليست
سوا كلها سخافات ولا قيمه
لها كل من يحاول تبرير انه عميل بالقول
ضغطوا
عليه صدقيني اذهبي وتحدثي مع الناس مع
افراد الشاباك وغيرهم تلك ليست وسائل قلت
لك سابقا ان لم يكن هناك ثقه ضربه في
اللقاء
الثاني احصلي على الثقه ولا شيء مهم
بعدها بمجرد ان تكون هناك ثقه بين الجميع
استطيع ان امنح العميل كل شيء على سبيل
المثال استطيع ان اعطيه مسدسا بيده دون ان
اخاف من انه يحمل مسدسا
امامي في الطريق لمعرفه المزيد عن طرق
الاسقاط تبين ان اسرائيل لا تكتفي بالضغط
على الفلسطينيين عبر احتياجاتهم الانسانيه
وانما تمارس ادوارا نفسيه في الاسقاط
وتلعب على حبل الثقه واهام العملاء بحرصها
الانساني عليهم لاستدراج وهذا ما حصل مع
احد العملاء الذين سمحت لنا الاجهزه
الامنيه في غزه بتسجيل اعترافاتهم عبر
كاميرا سريه وضعت في غرفه
[موسيقى]
التحقيق بدات اشتغلت
فيرزات اللي هي فتره يمكن تسع شهور طول
الفتره هذه ما سالني عمره سالني عن حاجه
كان يسالني دائما عن العمال كل سؤاله كان
عن العمال عن ايرز قلي يا اخي انا ما بدي
شي منك انا بدي اياك بس انت صديق بدي اياك
انا بس ترد علي تقوللي كيف حالك تطمني عنك
واطمنك عني وبس انا ايش بدي منك وانا بدي
اساعدك بدي احطلك مساعده في المنطقه
تاخذها وتضبط حالك انا ما بدي شي منك بدي
بس تقوللي كيف حالك وطمني عليك كل ما يهم
قبل كل شيء هو ان تكون انسانا كي تمنحهم
الثقه لانه وبعد وجود الثقه لن يكون هناك
عمل لن يتم تشغيل اي عميل المخابرات
الاسرائيليه حقيقه اقولها انها ابدعت
وبرعت في استخدام الاساليب النفسيه وجدنا
عده حالات ورصدنا عده حالات انه دار حديث
مع احد الاشخاص وهو يعني متعلم وعلى مستوى
راقي من العلم الا انه في النهايه وقع
وكان ضحيه ال
اسلوب اختراق الوعي او يسمى احيانا بكي
الوعي مكالمه جديده وعميل جديد يدعى ناصر
فرعون تحدثنا اليه وعلمنا بطريقه اسقاطه
فيما يسمى بغرف العصافير علي ق بعطيك هويه
بعطيك مصاري
بعطيك رخصه بعطيك
دارهم بشتغل معهم في الغ العصفير العالم
اللي تدمرت ها برا في الضفه وقطع تح راس
العصافير سووا حالهم شيوخ وسووا حالهم
اي انبياء وسووا حالهم شرفاء وهم اوسق من
الكنابس موضوع العصافير بيعمل على مساله
في غايه الاهميه وهي عمليه تغييب الوعي
يعني انا عشت تجربه الاسر وعشت تجربه
العصافير تخيل ان الذي يعني كان اي يؤم
بنا الصلاه ويخطب بنا الجمعه وكان يوميا
يحفظ الصفحه من القران ويطلب مني ان اسمع
ح له انا كنت اتعجب لم اجد لحظه واحده
للتفكير ان اشك في هذا الانسان قد يكون
مرتبط مع
المخابرات غرف العصافير فكره تقوم على دس
عملاء داخل السجون للحصول على معلومات من
السجناء بدات المخابرات الاسرائيليه في
استخدام هذه الطريقه في السبعينيات عقب
لجوء عميل اليها لحمايته بعد انكشاف امره
رحله البحث عن هذا العميل حملت لنا مفاجاه
كبرى عبد الحميد رجوب هو من اوائل من عمل
على تاسيس
هذه الغرف او هذا
الاسلوب
من التحقيق مع المناضلين والاسرى عبر
ايهام بان بانهم يدخلوا الى غرف معتقلين
ومناضلين وفي النتيجه يخرجوا وهم مقدمين
المعلومات انا
اسست
علنا وتحذير مسبق ساحارب
بكل الوسائل وتحالف مع الشيطان نفسه ان
وجد اني
ادمركم رحت للمخابرات طلبتهم قتلهم بدي
اعمل واحد اثلا بدي احول الغرفه او الغرف
في سجون لمراكز تحقيق فدانا الغرفه الاولى
بجنين بعدها افتتح غرف في كل موقع فبدات
سيرتي مع
الدوله مع
اسرائيل وتطورنا
وانتشرت الفكره على مستوى اسرائيل معظم
الاعترافات التي يعترف بها ابناء المقاومه
او الاسرى في السجون هي من خلال العصافير
احنا مهمتنا كانت تحقيق بدل ما اقعد شهرين
وثلاث في الزنازين انا قصرت عليه لمده
ساعه سالنا عبد الحميد الرجوب عن الطريقه
التي كان يستدرج بها المعتقلين للاعتراف
فاقر انه كان يدعي انه مسؤول في حركه فتح
سلاحي فتح تنظيم فتح هو بيحكي ل فتح مش ي
بحكي لم خافظ بحكي لمسؤول فتحي انا لبست
ثو فتحي ما فيش منا احنا جوسيس احنا عم ما
فيش مننا احنا ج احنا
عم كل كل عميل بمستوى عبد هو جندي اهم من
اي جندي في وحداتنا العسكريه في جف
في
الملينه كان عباره عن مسمار صغير في كعب
احتلال كل شيء يبدا
بمسمار كيف يتخابر العميل مع الاحتلال وما
هي طرق
تواصله تمكنا من الحصول على الاعترافات
الكامله لعميل اعد داخليه غزه بعد كشفه
يدعى اشرف عويضه وكان مشغله الاسرائيلي
يعمل تحت اسم اياد كعاده المشغلين
الاسرائيليين في استعارت للاسماء العربيه
كانت بيني وبين اياد الاتصال من هنا على
طريق الميرت لما كنت في اير الصناعيه
بعديها جاني جوال كشاف واشتغلت عليه تصوير
لانه هو الجهاز بصور و وبكلم في نفس الوقت
كل واحد فيله اشاره معينه بلاك الاشاره
المعينه تبعته برفع التليفون للمفاعيل
بقوله شو بقوله بكره الساعه كذا وكذا
نتلاقه بال
الدور الاشاره الليب عباره عن دوريه وبيجي
من نص فيدي زي حز نص زي علامه الكف عارف
ق ب مكتوب فوق مثلا الساعه 10 بكتبو لي
الساعه 12 تحتك التاريخ 16 وكتبوا لي
ه اناس كيف بشوف الاشاره بس علي ازيد
ساعتين وزيد يومين و حن حنزله او رسمه
حنظله حنظله كان
ش بدل ان تكون يداه مربوطتين الى الخلف
اجعلهما
مفتوحتين عندما تراه على الحائط تعرف انه
لك
بعد طول انتظار وصلتنا الموافقه لمقابله
فتحي حماد والذي عمل طويلا وما زال في ملف
العملاء وشرح لنا الطريقه التي يتم فيها
تنظيم التخابر مع العملاء والتي لا تكون
من المشغل للعميل مباشره وانما يمكن
للتعليمات ان تصل بواسطه عميل اخر يستخدم
العدو نقاط الاتصال انطر اليه في توصيل
الاموال
والتوجيهات اسلوب النقاط الميته بمعنى
يقول لفلان ضع الاموال في نقطه معينه او
التعليمات في نقطه معينه وطبعا يراقبو
بالاتصال و بالطياره بدون طيار ثم يقول
العمل الفلاني اذهب الى المنطقه الفلانيه
وخذ في المربع الفلاني عند كذا
كذا يعني احنا نكون خم ونص س
نتح السل السل ونمشي قد هو كان يستناني جو
كانوا يستنون الجيو تكون في سياره اغير
فيها ملابس
[موسيقى]
كلها طلب مني في الاخر في قاللي بدي احطك
امانه لقيت اللي هو فيها اربع
خشبات فتحت لقيت في في خشب من الخشبات
اللي هي اللي فتحت لقيت فيها اللي هو جوال
ولقيت فيها مبلغ من
مصار صار يقوللي مثلا اول مره قال حطلي
خشبه الاولى عتها هيك حطها في
المكان وحط الخشب الثاني في المكان
الفلاني حطيته ليس في حاجه بان يقوم فلان
بتوصيل معلومات والتوجيهات وانما عبر
الاتصال عبر الاتصال الخيطي وبتالي اذا ما
كشف عميل يك بذاته ولا يستطيع مهما حققت
معه لا يستطيع كشف اي عميل اخر لماذا لانه
مرتبط ارتباط خيطي وليس
هرمي لا يوجد في الموضوع هيكل هرمي لا
يوجد هرميه فالعميل هو ذئب وحيد ليس لديه
شركاء لان الشركاء دوما يتسببون في ان
تكشف
[موسيقى]
تقاطعت لدينا اعترافات العملاء حول الثمن
المقبوض لقاء خدمتهم لاسرائيل ا بتجيبي
مان 5000
دولار اذا بتجيبي معلومات مثلا بتشخط
سياره انه تصفي بني
ادمش
اعطوك بارخ 20 ال دولار 50 الف دولار تلو
يمين البني ادم وهيك بشتل مثلا بتسلم خليه
انا والله بتعرفي انا الخليه سلمتها دفعو
لي وعدوني ب 200 ال دولار دفعو لي 7000
دولار نصبوا علي حتى هي رخصه معناته في
سلاح هويتي
الشخصيه بتاك لواحد الا لما يكون واحد بيس
المسا وواحد مخابرات كثير يعني اللي هو
الغرف الصفيه
اليوني اذا كانت الهويه الاسرائيليه لا
تمنح الا لمستوى معين من العملاء اذا كيف
تمكن صادي من البقاء في
اسرائيل تعززت لدينا الشكوك بشان انكاره
التخابر مع اسرائيل وهو ما تاكدنا منه بعد
ان رصدنا لقائه مع عبد الحميد الرجوب واذا
اشتغلت مع الدوله ومظلوم عندي ه اللي بحكي
معه طب ماجيب لك الاوق تبع بدي اثبات شخصي
انك كنت تشتغل مع الدوله مع ركاز معين اسم
حركه معين هويه معينه
ابي ركز عن بدي شي نعيم بعرفه شايك بعد
شايك بعديها
بعرفه في وراق لك رقم الك كان ال رقم
استعمله 482 اتصلت في حدا لا عن طريق
احدهم لا والله حاولت اغط لحالي على اساس
اعيش فيط ماش
مغط هلا فهمت انت قلتلي انك انت ما خدم
اسرائيل لا خدم خدم
ه خدم ط ليش بتقول ما
خد 67
شهر خدمت اسرائيل وقصرت في او ما عرفتش
طريق المواصله انا بعرف صح دغري صح انت
عارف اذا بتقوللي قك رقم حركه معين معناته
صح هذا من نوعيه هذا في يمكن 1 ال مهيم في
اسرائيل اذا انت بتعرفيش
ار الالاف من يحتاج لالاف من اجل تشغيل
الاف يجب ان يكون الشباك منظمه ضخمه فشغل
العملاء لا يستطيع ان يشرف على 2000 عميل
ولا حتى على عشرات العملاء فالعمل يلزمها
وقت لمقابلتهم والتفكير والتخطيط وكتابه
التقارير لا ذلك ليس حقيقيا هذه الظاهره
تعتبر
صغيره جدا جدا مقارنه بالاعداد الهائله
التي تقدم التي تنضم الى المقاومه وتنضم
الى
احكام المجتمع الفلسطيني وساد
ثغراته محاوله احباط المجتمع الفلسطيني
انه دير بالك انت ب حارتك كلها عملاء دير
بالك انت ببلدك كلها عملاء وهذا غير صحيح
محاوله التشكيك ونشر الاشاعات مهمه رخيصه
للفت في عضد المجتمع الفلسطيني وهي مهمه
يبرع فيها
العملاء العبد انيه بنته متجوزه في السباع
بلش احكي في هذا الموضوع يا عمي هو قاعد
رئيس وحكومه ورئيس دوله وبنته متجوزه في
السبع دخيل الله ايش شو هذا لما كنت اتكلم
في السياره اي بين نساوين النساوين معقوله
بنته ايه ايش اللي بصير هذا روحوا النسوين
يشيع في الشوارع في هو يتعمد يقول لي نق
نسوين احكي قدام نسوين ودور كبار في السن
اي لما يقوا راكبين معي تعون فتح اضرب في
تعون حماس لما يقب تعون حما اشوف الله يلا
ضابطين الامن وناح
وكويسين على كل على كل ميل اميل كان
السلوك اتجاه تجنيد عملاء ليس فقط سلوك من
اجل المعلومات فقط بل من اجل تدمير النسيج
الاجتماعي الفلسطين اردنا ان نعرف اكثر عن
مهمات العملاء لكن حجم التكتم والرفض جدار
امني صلب مشترك بين العملاء ومغليه هي
اسرار امنيه ممنوع ح احكيها في شغلات كمان
ممنوع احكيها موضوع انه انا بدي اضلني
بالسجن شو تروحين اضلني
بالسجن ثلاث مواضيع انا بحكي فيها تفاصيل
مهمات امنيه
اغتيالات وعناصر فاعله في المخابرات اي
تهديد لحياه بني ادم بحك
سلفي ساقول لك ببريه بسيطه جدا لا يجب ان
نحاول الوصول لنوع من الحوار يقود الى
تعريض حياه شخص اخر للخطر من اجل سبق
الصحفي انا لا يمكن اصل لحد واحد يغتالني
ولو بدي اخش في تفاصيل احداث معينه بعرف
انه ابطال الاحداث بصون
ويقتلون من الشعب الفلسطيني وم الشعب
اليهودي خلال مقابلته بقي رجوب متحفظا في
اجاباته عن اي تفاصيل فساله عن بعض المهام
التي قام بها من قبل فذكر لنا متى تم
البدء في التخطيط لاغتيال خليل الوزير ابو
جهاد انا رحت على لبنان لمهمه خاصه بحكي
عنها بين قوسين اللي من خلالها عرفت انه
بدات المفاوضات السريه مع فت
بعد حرب لبنان
مباشره بدات المفاوضات السريه وانا دخلت
على خط امني معين من خلاله عرفت انه في
مفاوضات سريه مع مين ما كنت اعرف ولا عرفت
عرفت دوري
يعني فاللي ممكن كان يوقف في طريق السلام
بدو عن
الشارع مش مهم باي صوره من الصور استغلوا
عداوته مع فلان استغلوا كذا واشي بديهم
اشتغل فزح اللي عن الشارع كله منهم ابو
جهاد قرار ابو جهاد تخذ يمكن ما بعرف في
فتره معينه بيلزم يكون
موجود فزعوا على الشارع واجت
السلطه حكمل المار انا ابو جد قه تيار في
فدي لازم يخد ضيع الرئيس ضيع الزعيم هذا
معروف معروف بدش تحليلات كثير
يعني شوفي قتل
الشخصيه في اسرائيل او في امريكا مش مهم
ليه لانه شخصيه مات لانه هذا بيتراس تيار
التيار قائم وموجود في فتح لا راح الذرب
راح كل شي اثناء الحديث رفض عبد الحميد
الكشف عن شخصيه العميل الذي شارك في
اغتيال ابو جهاد لكن كلامه اجاب على
استفسار لطالما دار في بالنا حول طبيعه
الاهداف والشخصيات التي يكلف العملاء
باستهدافها لم يكن الانتماء التنظيمي هو
المحدد للاستهداف وانما طبيعه ما تمثله
هذه الشخصيات ذات الامر تكرر مع قاده حركه
حماس بعدها بسنوات يحيى عياش كان احد قاده
كتائب عز الدين القسام ولم يكن من الممكن
الوصول اليهم بدون عنصر
بشري الامساك بعياش بدون عميل كان خطيرا
جدا لا اعتقد انه كان بالامكان ايجاد مكان
يحيى عياش فاي جاده بدون عميل امر ليس مثل
البحث عن ابره في كومه قشم فحسب وانما
كالبحث عن الكومه فاين هي الكومه حتى نجد
الابره كان عياش مطاردا من عده جهات وتمت
عمليه اغتياله بانفجار هاتف محمول اوصله
اليه العميل كمال حماد احد اقارب صديقه
الذي خباه في
بيته حتى لو ان يحيى عياش فكك الهاتف لما
عرف ابدا انه مفخخ فان لم يكن لك دماغ
مجرم لا تستطيع ان تعمل في الشباك اي انه
كان يتوجب عليهم ان يضعوا انفسهم مكان
يحيى عياش كي يعرفوا ما سيفعله بهذا
الهاتف وكيف سيفك او هل
سيفك اغتيال شخص مثل يحيى عياش يلزمه
موافقه رئيس الحكومه بدون موافقه رئيس
الحكومه ما كان ذلك سيتم لان رئيس الحكومه
مسؤول عن الشبك تمت تصفيه عياش لان شمعون
بيريس اراد ذلك بشده كي يتفاخر ويقول
فعلناها ومن اجل ان يجعلهم ينسون موضوع
رابين قبل الانتخابات رابين قتل في نوفمبر
وعياش تم اغتياله في يناير والانتخابات
كانت في مارس كل شيء
سياسي رابين كان مطلعا على سر عميل عمليه
كابوتشي بنفسه وكان يتلقى معلومات محدثه
بعد كل لقاء انا
اش اعتقال الاب كابوتشي الذي اقلق اسرائيل
بتهريبه للسلاح من اجل المقاومه استلزم
ادخال عميل الى صفوف حركه فتح وتربيته
هناك ومشاركتهم في حمل سلاح الى ان تمكن
من حيازه ثقه
القياده ارسلوه الى دمشق الى ضواحي دمشق
ليعلموه كيف يفكك الاسلحه من السيارات
وكيف
يخرجها وحصلنا على الاشاره الاولى كانت
السياره التي علموه عليها سياره مرسيدس
وهكذا بدا رويدا رويدا الى ان حاز في
النهايه على الثقه المطلقه ثقه الطرف
الاخر في القطاع الغربي فاعطوه رقم هاتف
المطران كابوتشي في
القدس سالنا روني شكيد عن دوره في اعتقال
الاب
كابوتشي كنت ما يسمى برجل ميدان كنت
مسؤولا عن الرجل الذي جند العميل
كانت بعض ادوار العملاء صغيره ولا يلقى
لها بال بنقل معلومات قد لا يلتفت اليها
العميل او حتى من يقوم
بمراقبته لكن التفاصيل التي تم تتبعها
اوضحت اهميه اي معلومه ولو بسيطه في
عمليات كبيره لاغتيال كبار قاده المقاومه
الفلسطينيه هذا ما حدث مع الشيخ احمد
ياسين لا شيخ سنا يا مع الشيخ ياسين كان
الامر سهلا جدا لم تكن هناك مشكله لم يكن
يحتاج لعمل كثير فالجميع يعرفه وكانوا
يعرفون من هو واين هو فهو لا يختبئ كان
الامر ببساطه يتطلب معرفه متى يتم اخذه
للمسجد ومتى يتم اخراجه منه كان شخصا
معروفا على كرسي متحرك اذا كان يمكن رؤيته
من طائره او برج
مراقبه من جاء واعطى الاشاره ان الشيخ
رحمه الله خرج من المسجد فالعميل الارضي
يحل هذا اللغز في اخر لحظه ما القادر على
شرح المعلومه التي تاتي من المجال
الالكتروني هو
العميد لم يكن الشيخ ياسين وحده من تعرض
للاغتيال بسبب العملاء فبعده باسابيع
قليله قصفت طائره اسرائيليه سياره الدكتور
عبد العزيز الرنتيسي بعد ان ارشد العميل
اشرف عويضه عليه وهو بداخلها واكد ذلك
اعترافاته التي حصلنا على نسخه منها كانت
جايه سياره قبل العشاء صباره 83 لونها
ابيض وفي قلبها ثلاث اشخاص قلتله بدك
اصورها قاللي لا احنا
مستعجلين كان عبد العزيز الرنتيسي مقصوف
في هذه السياره وانا ما بعرف لكن هو قاللي
احنا كنا بدنا نوجه له رساله خفيفه لكن
صارت رساله
النهايه العميل ما بنقوش شو الهدف من
العمليه اعطينا معلومات والباقي مش عليك
عمليه تحديد العمليه جمع الخيوط من كذا
عميل مش من واحدين متكب المعلومات
الاستخباريه نحصل عليها من عده جهات وليس
من عميل واحد كالمسبحه 32 خرزه لا تكفي
تلزمك الث3 وليس بالضروره ان تكون كلها من
مكان واحد تجمعها من هنا وهناك وفي
النهايه يصبح عندك مسبحه وهكذا تنتهي
القصه هل تنتهي القصه عندما تنتهي خدمه
العميل وهل يوفى العميل حقه بعد ادائه
لخدماته يعني انا كمان شهرين مروح وينده
يرموني على المحسوب بعدها اه برد ارجع
لاسرائيل بهرب برد انحبس فاهمه هي حياتي
شو هالحياه هيني خسرت شعبي خسرت اهلي خسرت
وطني خسرت شع فيش معي شي حتى هويه فيش معي
علمنا من نديم ان العميل فؤاد ابو سريه
سوف يخرج اليوم وان الجيش سيلقيه على
الحاجز فانتظرنا ساعات طويله هناك انا صار
لي ه 10 دقائق الجندي اول ما نزلت من
السياره مسكني من هنا بقول لي انت اللي
بتستنوا في قلع
نيم اخذونا لحم وزتونه عظم بقول لك احنا
المخابره واحنا واحنا بساعدكم واحنا بنقيم
واحنا بحظكم واحنا كل شيء وهي ولما
بياخذوا اللي بدهم اياه كل شيء زتنا زي
الكلاب شفت زي الكلاب بزتو هو انا لو اني
قتلت حالي ومتت وريحت بتريح بس انا صل ع
سنه كل يوم
بموت بعد غياب الشمس اتصل بنا وقال بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي اعاده الى الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بعد ايام قليله علمنا بتسل
مجددا الى اسرائيل هو تماما زي محارم
الورق يستعملوه ليمسحوا في الاوساخ ومن ثم
كب في سله المهملات في سله الزباله نتيجه
لرفضهم وتهديد حياتهم يفر العملاء بعد ان
يكشفوا هاربين الى اسرائيل ظنا منهم انهم
قد يجدون ملجا امنا لكنهم يواجهون الرفض
ذاته من الفلسطينيين خلف الخط الاخضر قسم
كبير من العملاء بداوا بالنزوع الى داخل
الخط الاخضر اسسنا
لجنه سميناها
لجنه مقاومه عملاء او اللجنه لطرد العملاء
في قسم منهم عملاء وقسم منهم غربا عمال
الدنيا مخلوطه يعني ما بتعرفيش مين
العميل انت من غزه كيف عايش هون
مزاج جاسوس
جاسوس لا وانت لا انا من
هونش في الطيره يوجد لجنه تعمل ضد العملاء
وان كان هناك شخص يشكون بانه عميل فسيا
خذون في الصباح ويلقون به في الشارع
ويحرقون بيته ويطردونه
يلا هنا يقع احد بيوت العملاء وقد احرقه
اهالي القريه تعبيرا عن رفضهم القاطع لهذه
الظاهره
مره انا بقول لزياد ايش رتبتي عندكم يا
زياد قاللي انت الذراع الاولى لدوله
اسرائيل والطويله قاللي انا م لقيتش واحد
بشخصيتك ولا بقوتك ولا يمكن ولا يمكن يعني
قبير بيقوللي بيعو اف 18 قلت شو بعرفني
قالل لا
بعونا فيش دوله بتبيع سلاحها الوحيد لدوله
ثانيه وانت من اسلحتنا الوحيده ما ببيعك
لول احن بنتون
معهم نبيعك انا ما شفت ولا عميل صار
مليونير ولا خائن صار صاحب شركه يعني حتى
الذين هربوا الى اسرائيل وتنسوا هناك انا
بعرف وبعرف معلومات وشفت مقابلات لهم على
الوسائل الاعلام العبريه انا اقول لك هم
يعيشوا
حياه انا صارلي 17 محاوله اغتيال قال لي
انت
عننا عقيد لانه انت ميداني على الارض انت
في
الارض تم اعدام العميل اشرف عويضه احد
اخطر العملاء في غزه بعد ان اعترف انه
شارك في عمليات اغتيال ل 15 شخصا من قاده
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الاجهزه الامنيه في
قطاع غزه كانت حقيقه تمارس حربا يعني خفيه
في صيد هؤلاء الافاعي من خلال نشر هذه
الاساليب وكشفها لابناء شعبنا الفلسطيني
فتحنا باب العوده والاوبه الى احطان الشعب
وسلم عدد من العملاء انفسهم قبل ان
يتورطوا وتعاهدنا نحن من جانبنا بالتستر
عليهم وبعدم ملاحقتهم هناك
بعض ذوي العملاء الذين اصروا على تسليم
ابنائهم الذين شكوا فيهم وتم معالجه الامر
بيننا
وبينهم اذا ما تجرا الشباك على الاتصال
باحد من غزه فسيح عليه بالموت في نفس
اليوم فكل واحد قبل ان يدخل الى اسرائيل
او يرجع انا متاكد ان لحماس وحدات لا تخفى
على احد تحارب هؤلاء الاشخاص
خلال عشرات الاعوام شنت اسرائيل حربا
استخباراتيه موازيه للاعمال العسكريه ضد
الفلسطينيين وجهت خلالها ضربات قاسيه
للعمل النضالي في عام 2006 نجحت فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في اسر الجندي كعاد
شاليط لتشكل تداعيات العمليه نقله نوعيه
في الصراع المخابرات بين الطرفين عمل
خلالها الشباك بكل قوته للحصول على اي
معلومه تدل على مكان شليط حتى وصل الامر
الى نشر العملاء في الشوارع تحت اي غطاء
احدها كان فتاه تنكرت في هيئه
متسوله تم اسقاط هذه الفتاه وكان دورها ان
تبحث في كل الشوارع والاذقه عن المكان
الذي يتواجد به شلي ثم كانت تمارس دور
انها تتسول في احد البيوت حتى تستطيع ان
تصل الى معلومات قد توصلها الى ش طوال خمس
سنوات باءت جميع المحاولات لمعرفه مكان
الجندي الاسرائيلي بالفشل كان السر هو في
تعامل المقاومه مع الشباك بذات الاساليب
التي
يستخدمها من جهز
للعمليه ربما بنى خندقا او حط طابقا علويا
فوق بيت
ما يشركون الكل بالسر ولا يعرف الكل ما
يوجد اي ان الدائره التي تعرف السر عددها
قليل ظاهره العمله هي يعني تستند في
محاربتها الى صراع ادمغه بيننا وبين العدو
[موسيقى]
الصون حماس لم حماس تعلمت الامر وبما ان
حماس تعلمت ذلك شغلت دماغها هذه المره فال
الاستخبارات هي صراع عقول وليس قوه وعلي
فقد نجحوا ومن قال بان الشباك ينجح دائما
يمكن ان
يفشل العدو يقوم بتطوير نفسي نحن بالمقابل
نقوم باكتشاف هذه الامور نقوم بتط بعمليه
التطوير في التوع واللاحقه والاعتقال
والتحقيق نشروا كتابا فيه كيف نكافح
الشباك وكيف لا تكون عميلا لش كل عميل
لديه برنامج عمل فعندما يضبط يهدم هذا
الكيان تماما ويمنع شر
كبير انا فخور بان دوله اسرائيل تنفق على
هذا المجال في كل سنه مئات
الملايين ا
حرب
مفرداتها المال واستغلال الحاجات واستهداف
الوعي والاساليب
النفسيه يقابلها مقاومه شديده ورفض مجتمعي
وحرب عقول تدور رحاها بين فلسطينيين يسعون
للتحرر وبين احتلال يسعى لحفظ امن الدوله
المحتله والابقاء
عليها كلما اشتدت المقاومه
كلما ركز العدو في تكثيف ظاهره
العمله في النهايه ساقول شيئا لا يتوجب
علي ان اقوله بدون العملاء من غير الممكن
لا يوجد امن لا امن
[موسيقى]
بدون
ا
[موسيقى]
م y